algerians have voted in a referendum
they're deciding whether to approve
changes to the constitution
it follows months of anti-government
protests and anger
so does algeria need a new constitution
and how will it affect the balance of
power
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim zhum last year algeria's
protest movement toppled long-time
leader abdal aziz bhutalika
but protesters are still demanding
change because they say many of the old
political elite are still in charge
new president abdelmajid taboon has
promised to address their complaints
on sunday his government held a
nationwide referendum to approve
changes to the constitution they include
the introduction of presidential term
limits
giving more powers to parliament and
allowing the military to be deployed
abroad
but many algerians say the changes don't
go far enough
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
first this report from muhammadval
for nearly two years millions of
algerians have been demanding
change they say they want a more
balanced system of power sharing
a stronger popular representation and
guarantees of social and individual
rights president abdemajit taboon
promised to address
those demands through amendments to the
constitution
if approved they'll limit presidents to
serve only two terms in office
and give the president the ability to
appoint a prime minister
from his own party if it wins a majority
and crucially it will give parliament
the power to remove the prime minister
through a motion of no confidence
the government says the amendments
respond to people's fundamental
aspirations by establishing a genuine
democracy
and there are more changes planned on
social and individual freedoms
we don't recognize this system in power
and this constitution if passed will
plunge us into the abyss
just as the predecessors of those in
power plunged us into the abyss
we do not recognize them the reform is
designed to turn the page on a history
of
centralized powers and military
intervention in algerian politics
i swear that whatever they do we will
not stop until we achieve independence
and i swear that we will continue to
fight until this regime falls
the protest movement otherwise known as
iraq forced the resignation
of president abdul aziz bhuttaflira in
april last year
after months of mars rallies but
government critics say
his loyalists both civilian and military
still
run the country even after the
presidential election
that was organized in december in an
attempt to bring
change all five presidential candidates
in that election were part of the former
government
the election saw the lowest turnout in
algeria's history
the date november 1st is symbolic for
algerians
it's the 66th anniversary of the
beginning of the war
of independence from colonial france
but the mood of national solidarity that
algeria witnessed on that day
45 years ago is largely absent today
because of political division muhammad
algeria has a long history of unrest
that goes back more than 30 years
in 1988 riots forced constitutional
changes that led to the first
multi-party system in 1992 a military
coup preventing the islamic salvation
front from winning elections
sparked a civil war seven years later
aziz butaflica became president
and played a role in bringing an end to
the war but his bid to stand for a fifth
term last year sparked mass protests and
led to his resignation
abdemajit taboon took over in a
controversial election
promising to launch a new algeria
protesters say the government hasn't
done enough
to meet their demands
all right let's bring in our guests in
casablanca yasmin hasnowi
a north african affairs specialist in
beirut
dalia ghanim a resident scholar at the
malcolm h kerr
carnegie middle east center and in paris
research fellow at the school for the
advanced studies in the social sciences
welcome to each of you yes mean let me
start with you
does this new constitution meet the
demands of protesters who have been
calling for political change well
actually um um actually mohammed as the
algerians are set to vote today
in a constitutional referendum which
concides with the anniversary of it's
very important with the start of
algeria's war of independence from
france
from 1954 to 1964. algeria's
leaders they see today's constitution as
an important part
of the strategy to move beyond algeria's
popular
unrest however uh many algerians as
i've heard it you know as you know in
the i heard it in the in
the documentary that many algerians not
believe those who participated in the
in in the heroic street seem skeptical
about many things first they they seem
skeptical about the articles of the
constitution
the applicability of the constitution
adding to that
the algerian opposition and we've seen
that during the campaign of the
referendum in the in in last month that
they were
they rejected the the constitution and
they
you know they opposed to go to the polls
and uh
decides that they because they see that
the constitution
is a way to distract attention from the
old ruling elite continued grip on power
so
i think it's also important to know that
uh
today's referendum uh comes at a time
when
a bemidji that boon is hospitalized in
in overseas in germany and many
observers see
that the new constitution represents a
centerpiece of abdil mejita boone's
strategy to neutralize or actually to
contain the the herak movement
when it staged you know vast
demonstration
last year while others see this it's
very important while others see
they they see that the insurances that
have been
conveyed with the with the with the
people of his
cabinet that the constitutional
proposals were formulated on the
foundation of
a modern state a new algeria as he he
mentioned several times
while serving citizens yes i mean i
think
i think he has been unable to convince
it's very important is that it has been
enabled to convince the opposition the
lawyers
and also those that the algerian
citizens that are still frustrated about
this
current new constitution all right uh
dalia let me ask you
what are the main points then proposals
that are at play
in this constitutional referendum yes uh
sure but before that i want to say
something
the change of the constitution or the
amendment
of the constitution where never actually
uh one of the demands of the herak the
herak never asks for that
this is why this is a non-event so
as a matter of fact the constitutional
revision was adopted already on friday
september 11 by
the council of ministers and by the
national popular assembly
the lower house of parliament and the
senate so what are
uh the the what does it contain the
document contains 73 recommendations
divided into six main areas
including strengthening the power of
the separation of powers uh the
president prerogative the head of the
government
and parliament and the judiciary and the
fight against corruption
but mainly the president will not
actually
uh exercise supposedly
exercise more than two consecutive or
separate mandates
and the prime minister will be directly
accountable to parliament
but behind this choice it is very
important
to keep in mind that actually nothing
really
changed uh the the the the regime
is keeping is maintaining if i may say
the concentration of power at the palace
of el moradia in the hands of
the president who they choose and
who chose this we are talking here about
the military so the military in algeria
remain the real locus of power and they
do
what they have always done meaning place
a man at the presidential palace with a
hyper power
and control him this is the political
domination of the military
of the military sorry this is the
political domination
of the military over civilians and
in a nutshell civil military
relationships in algeria
didn't really change since the
independence of the country
in 1962. opposition leaders
and activists have denounced this
referendum as a ploy
simply for the regime to hold on to
power to
buy more time what do you say well we
have to understand that there's a huge
crisis now in algeria
if we talk about the constitution the
constitution will be passed
today and it will be adopted and and
aldriya will have a constitution that is
has uh dalia mentioned giving
all power to uh all that is built on
supremacy presidential powers
and uh uh presidential paris over the
parliament of a justice but also in
in in real partnership and that's the
first time that is mentioned as such in
a constitution
with the army now with the absence of
tiburn
algeria is getting back to its all
crisis political crisis
of what kind of balance between the
military
and the presidential facet algeria can
have
and it's not just a crisis that has
followed
the impeachment or or the resignation of
budva as such we
since but actually the regime really has
not really been able to
decide what kind of project what kind of
vision what kind of
balance between the civil and the
military state he wanted
but now uh with the absence of taboon we
are even getting back to a crisis
that we can that has started in 1992
since the army has cancelled the
elections elections that have been won
by
at that time the islamic salvation front
and islamist party
the crisis that it had had hurt really
uh
of algeria today is
what kind of political life without real
political participation
can the regime maintain with the absence
of taboon
what kind of revolutionary legitimacy
can he steal or constitutional
legitimacy can he
uh can the regime still uh uh play with
without a request of or without
requesting
institutions without having new
institutions without launching a new
transition
uh so really what is occurring currently
in algeria is a
node crisis that is once again put ahead
uh with the absence of taboo and there's
no way
the algerian algeria can get out this
crisis
even with a new president if tibun don't
come back soon
yes i mean you heard dalia and emma both
speak a little bit about the role of the
military in algeria in their answers i
want to ask you to expand a little bit
on that
because one of the proposed changes in
the constitution
in the referendum now relates to the
army it would allow them for the first
time to be deployed
outside of national territory on
international peacekeeping missions
are there concerns about what the
implications of this would be
for the military and and for society
well actually yes because um i think
that that that
man amendment uh is is first of all is
vague
and uh it was put actually because of
the threats you know you see like
but but the the terrorism threats in the
sahel what happens in libya
in mali etc but it puts a little bit
doubt about the
you know the the regional uh assets like
how this how algeria is going to deploy
it's it's you know its army and and
what what what benefits can it it can be
given to algeria
in order to deploy this army so i think
it's it's
it's a big it's a bit bit vague and
that's what uh
what's what happens is in the
constitution is that
many articles are vague and they have to
be redefined notably the deployment of
of of of the army uh there should be
like a kind of
law that structures the deployment of
the army we know we know what's
happening in the region you know what's
happening
uh with the conflict that is happening
in in libya in mali etc and
a little bit of issues between you know
that is happening between uh
you know uh morocco and and uh
and uh and algeria knowing that that
algeria is hosting uh
uh the polisario in its uh in its
territory so one has to
re-question that that the deployment and
it's among the reasons why
the you know the people in the herak are
are bit confused about
all these all these articles and it's
also the fact that
many who still want to take up the the
streets
despite the pandemic because because to
to demand a better balanced power
in in in the hope to steer the country
away from
authoritarianism so you know
people in the herak they see that they
see that
the the army is still does still have
have a power
uh even if now uh is hospitalized
in uh in them overseas but we see that
uh the general the uh the um
the acting of the armored forces general
serge
who conformed who has not been uh
neutral
uh in his position regarding the
constitution while
you know uh uh uh encouraging
the algerian to go to go to the polls so
i think
uh that gives a little bit you know
questions
uh to uh to everything and especially to
that deployment of the army overseas
that that has to be
redefined and and requested by the
international community
dalia since being elected has president
taboon
actually reached out to the hedok
protest movement
has there been any kind of dialogue
well unfortunately the answer is no
and by uh putting in place this
referendum i
believe that he is aggravating something
that
has started uh on february 22nd
2019 there is the legitimacy crisis
there is a profound crisis of trust and
legitimacy
in uh algeria let us as your report said
it first one should remember that the
election of abdullah majid
despite its rejection by a majority of
algerians
and the abstention rate was officially
at 60 percent and these are official
numbers
so one can imagine what where what was
the real number
uh then you have a president abdulmejit
boon who multiplied the declaration of
appeasement to work
towards the herak while in fact and in
practice
he also set in motion the repressive
machine with
dozens of arrests of journalists of
activists of ordinary
citizen of hierarchies and finally this
new constitution
is not a new move actually every
algerian president who came to power
tried to uh leave his sprint
by uh putting forward a new constitution
but what is very important to keep in
mind
is the difference between what butler
did and abdur majid's
came to power in 1999 he was popular
back then
and people voted for him in addition the
increase
in oil revenues back then led to a rise
in living
standards and the business class
subordination to the president and his
entourage
today this is really hard to reproduce
because of
difficult economic conditions so
algerians are
no longer in fact to willing
to accept a leadership model that
produced not legitimacy
but support through dependency and what
is
actually in fact if i may add two points
what is actually aggravating this
legitimacy crisis
beside the constitution and the economic
situation
that was exacerbated by the covet 19
crisis
and its poor management it's also the
political class inability to
implement the systemic and genuine
political changes for which algerians
are calling
and finally the departure of the
president to germany
finally the departure of the president
to germany and the total lack of
transparency regarding his condition
i mean algerians had to learn from the
saudi that their president was sick
this is a total disdain for the people
so the people's idealization
by the leadership in its public
statement in the constitution as we have
seen with the blessed herac
as the constitution stated while
actually
showing disdain for popular demands in
practice
that is unfortunately for the regime
something that algerians will not accept
anymore
critics of the government have said that
one of the reasons that
authorities in algeria are reluctant
to open up more political space there or
at least in a more definitive manner
is because they're afraid that they will
be held accountable
for their actions during the country's
civil war do you think that's the case
well of course that's that's always the
case that the military has
always been afraid to be held
accountable and that's why they
they they direly need
a president to be accountable for
the governance but again i believe that
the real crisis we are on
uh we are in in algeria beyond the issue
of constitution is really linked
to the possible absence of the boon for
the next month
and if we remember what happened in
april
uh 2019 when bud flirca
was not algeria's president anymore what
we did we witnessed we saw that
gaiitsama had the damn chief army and
staff
actually filled the vacuum of this uh
uh has the de facto head of the state
and now
uh we are in the same situation but we
are having aggravating
factors in terms of this crisis of
governmentality and balance between
civil and military military powers
we algeria is hardly
impacted by the coveted health
and education and social and economic
crisis
that has been aggravated by the kovid
and that tyboon has not been able to
manage well uh uh the the follow-up
scenario
even if as i said a new puppet president
is chosen
to uh take the place of admiration
won't solve any any any any question
because
it will even complicate things much more
because if you remember when at the
magic tribune came to power
he brought with him his own clienteles
his own clans
and people who have been judged by
algerians as highly incompetent so if
the new president
is chosen he will also have to bring his
own staff and it will take time and
algeria has not the luxury to loss to
those two
times more time and there's also a
problem of consensus
between the top generals on the kind of
successor they will choose
and that's also the main problem i see
especially in
in relationship with the algerian people
and the fact that they have been largely
boycotting the last presidential
elections
two days within random how can you
legitimize a new president
uh through new presidential elections
that will be
absolutely impossible to help yes i mean
we only have about three minutes left i
want to ask you about the opposition
in algeria because many have said that
the opposition there
has been weakened by not having
effective leadership
has the opposition actually been able to
articulate
a vision for the country well yes they
have been
very active with the herat with the
heraka uh
uh with the herak demonstrators
uh by the simple reason that they
rejected
during the campaign they were boycotting
the
the people to go to the uh to to to to
to the poll because uh because simply
for them for example
uh whatever was in the uh constitution
articles doesn't go in line with the
aspiration of the
people of the heroic and here i'm
talking about the the language i'm
talking about
identity algerian identity etc so i
think
that the real test for today and this i
it goes in line with what dalia says and
i agree with her
the real test for for this constitution
will be the rate of voters
today we're talking about the opposition
how many will go
we go to vote up until now we read for
example in
in the william of tiziwizu you have like
63 communes
that canceled the the the vote because
of security reasons
so one has to test the enthusiasm of the
algerian people besides the opposition
and the readiness
and conviction to go to to to to the
polls and also
during the campaign uh there were some
obstruction of this opposition
uh also the the the people from the
herac to uh
to to to have their say this is very
important that was not really they were
really
uh shunned away they were really
imprisoned
so i think that uh let's remember also
that
during the presidential election there
was like a
turnout of less than 40 percent of
people who would go to the vote so and
up until now
we have only six percent who went to the
to the polls so i think
uh i think everything is clear i think
that uh the
algerian leadership reit needs to
review uh it's uh it's it's it's it's
vision
uh there are the people are still the
same uh
because of that uh the algerians uh
don't have
their uh there is not a good cover news
i'm not talking about algeria but it's
everywhere
but the algerian has been infected for
more than 100 years
we talk about civilian war i don't think
that there will be civilian war anymore
because
the algerian have suffered a lot uh
because of the colonization for 100
years
the internal civil civil war but all
they need now
is is is a good governance all they need
now is is
is to find a like a good a good welfare
for them so i think that
um for that yes there will be uh
there will be uh uh uh people will vote
uh but i don't think it's gonna be at
the expectations of or at the aspiration
of the
uh herak people adding to that uh there
is call also for the uh
uh yes ma'am my great yes i mean i'm
sorry i'm sorry to interrupt but we we
have run out of time so we're going to
have to leave the conversation there
thanks to all our guests yes mean hasn't
we dalia ghanim and amel
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
for me mohammed jim zhum and the whole
team here bye for now
you